أعلنت سيرينا ويليامز ، بطلة البطولات الأربع الكبرى التي حصدت 23 مرة
، اعتزالها الوشيك
من نشر التنس على
إنستغرام الثلاثاء ، وقالت الفتاة البالغة من العمر 40 عامًا إن
هناك وقتًا في الحياة يتعين علينا فيه
أن نقرر التحرك في اتجاه مختلف
يكون الوقت دائمًا صعبًا عندما تحب.
شيء كثير من طيبتي ، أستمتع
بالتنس ، لكن الآن بدأ العد التنازلي ،
يجب أن أركز على أن أكون أمي
أهدافي الروحية وأخيرًا
اكتشاف سيرينا مختلفة ولكنها مثيرة ،
سأستمتع بهذه الأسابيع القليلة القادمة ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك  إنه لأمر رائع أن أكون
هنا
على مدار الـ 23 عامًا الماضية ، فقد أعادت تعريف
معنى أن تكون لاعبة رياضية ،
فهذه هي أعظم منصة
للرياضية وهي مكان رائع حيث
بدأت ويليامز في الظهور بعد
فوزها في الزوجي المختلط في بطولة ويمبلدون.
1998 وكان عمرها 17 عامًا فقط عندما
هزمت المصنفة الأولى عالميًا في ذلك
الوقت مارتينا هينجيس للفوز بالبطولة المفتوحة ، لقد
كنت أنتظر حياتي كلها لهذه
اللحظة التي كنت أمارسها
لسنوات عديدة و  كانت الولايات المتحدة المفتوحة مصممة
على أنني أردت حقًا الفوز ، فقد كانت
أول امرأة أمريكية من أصل أفريقي منذ عام
1958 تفوز بلقب فردي في البطولات الأربع الكبرى ، حيث
بدأت صعودًا مذهلاً ورحلة
أصبحت أختها منافسها فينوس ، وهو تحدي دائم
لعبها  الجزء الأول
هو لأنها جيدة جدًا والجزء الثاني
هو لأنها أختي
وأريد حقًا الأفضل لها بما
في ذلك لها الفوز بكل شيء معًا
كانوا على عكس أي شيء رأته التنس من
قبل سيرينا المتميزة والعزيمة
التي ستظهر مع المزيد من الألقاب التي تهزم
فينوس  في أربع نهائيات متتالية بدأت
في عام 2002 ، كان إنجازًا أطلق عليه لقب سيرينا سلام
ويليامز مسرورًا أيضًا بالظهور
كأيقونة أزياء وثقافية من الكورسيهات القطنية
إلى القواطع التي لم يفعلها أحد تمامًا
مثل سيرينا وكان شعورًا رائعًا
بحلول عام 2012 كان ويليامز قد
فاز بكل شيء تقريبًا  لكن في أولمبياد لندن ،
أكملت بطولة سيرينا الذهبية
، وحصلت على ألقاب فردية ومزدوجة عندما
خرجت إلى هناك ، أعتقد  أنا أحب الذهب ، إنه
لوني المفضل ، دعني أحصل على الذهب ، لا
أريد الحصول على الفضة ، دعني أحصل على الذهب ،
هذا ما أريد أن أصبحت قصتها بالفعل
من أسطورة هوليوود ،
وسوف تفوز سميث بجائزة الأوسكار وهي تلعب دور
والدها ، لقد كتبت لي  خطة مكونة من 78 صفحة
لمسيرتهم المهنية بالكامل قبل أن
يولدوا حتى الآن في الرياضة ،
يبدو أن إرثها المذهل قد سقط لحظة واحدة ، حيث فازت 23 مرة في
البطولات الأربع الكبرى بخجل من
الرقم القياسي على الإطلاق ، لكن يمكن القول إنه كان
أعظم فوز لها على شقيقتها فينوس
بينما كانت حاملاً لمدة ثمانية أسابيع في 2017
الأسترالية ، فتحت ابنتها أليكسيس
أوليمبيا أوهانيان جونيور ، ستغير حياتها
إلى الأبد ، لكن لم يكن تصميمها أبدًا على أن
تكون الأفضل ، فأنا أحب التنس
وأحب أن أعرف ما
أفعله والآن كان علي فقط
أن أمتلك  لتلتزم بي
تقول إنها تتطور بعيدًا عن الرياضة
ولكن فقط بعد أن تطورت الرياضة بسبب
كريستينا ماكفارلاند cnn london